all right well Tim Scott's Republican
Presidential candidacy off to an
explosive start opening the event in
North Charleston South Carolina with a
Dean scream I'll explain in a moment
then plagued by Audio issues you all
know I love it when these right Wingers
have audio issues that included the
largest agricultural
exactly right
um and then just saying completely
outrageous things and his campaign does
appear to be dead on arrival so as I
told you yesterday Republican senator
from South Carolina Tim Scott the only
black Republican in the Senate has
announced he is running for president of
the United States against Donald Trump
why Maga voters would switch from a
candidate who regularly scapegoats black
and brown people to a black guy I don't
know it doesn't seem like that's going
to appeal to them but
here is Tim Scott opening the event with
the dean's scream
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
for people who don't remember the dean's
scream this was the moment in 2014 that
ended Howard Dean's presidential chances
and I'm not saying it was right I'm just
saying it happened
and then we're going to Washington D.C
to take back the White House
[Applause]
exactly a moment that will live in
infamy uh Tim Scott in very melodramatic
fashion but this is all so stupid guys
in melodramatic fashion building to the
big announcement and I guess you could
say the crowd went wild I don't know you
tell me not less
we cannot have innocent people at risk
police officers getting ambushed and
attacked and seniors locked in their
homes from the time the sun goes down
until the sun comes up
Joe Biden and the radical left are
attacking every single rung of the
latter that helped me climb
and that's why
I'm announcing today
that I'm running
for president
of the United States
of America
all right
so anyway certainly a lot of energy
there happening
um and uh
he also made the strange claim that he's
the candidate the left is most scared of
which is interesting I'm the candidate
the far left fears the most
the far left is like who are you again
[Applause]
you see
when I cut your taxes
they called me a prop uh-oh when I
refunded the police
they called me a token
when I pushed back on President Biden
they even called me the n-word
the audience is like hmm I disrupt their
narrative I threatened their control the
truth of my life
disrupts their lies there you go I don't
know that the Republican audience is
going to go for this that's my sense
folks and we'll look at the polling in a
moment I I can't gloss over the massive
audio issues that they had and I'm
actually going to play for you the the
it feels like it goes on forever but it
doesn't I love this stuff America
is not a nation
uh-oh so the audio has now cut out
someone starts signaling him he's asking
which microphone is causing the problem
he's tapping his microphone he's wearing
a lapel mic and holding one he's
switching it on and off now he steps
forward it's getting awkward he's
talking into it but it's totally dead he
seemed to check his feet as if he had
like stepped on a cable and then now I
guess someone is going to maybe bring
him a different mic
okay now he's been handed a third
microphone this one's wired and it's
also not working he's talking into
multiple mics now and then he does he's
now he has the mic reversed almost about
to talk into the back end of the
microphone and then tapping the lapel
holding two mics and wearing a third one
this is unbelievable and now there's
cheering okay
and now he's back they were able to
survive the audio problems that's for
sure but I think Eric they're not like
they lived up I used to check it every
week are they buying are they buying
okay so
how this is the dumbest Republican
primary how is Tim Scott doing not
particularly well he has opened up this
race with an explosive
1.8 support behind at half the level of
support of Vivek ramaswamy
well behind Nikki Haley and Far Behind
Mike Pence who isn't even a candidate I
think it's important to know that being
said Tim Scott is ahead of Larry Elder
and I didn't even know Larry Elder was
considering running or that anyone was
thinking of Larry Elder as a candidate
but needless to say 1.8 percent it is
undeniable that Tim Scott's campaign is
completely dead on arrival but there's
someone that seems to be gushing with
excitement for Tim Scott and that's the
crew over at Fox and Friends on Fox News
let's talk about that next so Tim Scott
announces he's running for president uh
in the Republican primary I don't think
he has any shot at winning he's polling
1.8 percent Donald Trump welcomed it and
we know that the reason Trump welcomes
Scott running is Trump does better in
polling the more candidates there are
dividing up the non-trump votes so
Trump's glad for it the other people
that seem to be glad about it are the
Fox and Friends crew Steve Ducey and
Ainsley Earhart and Brian Kilmeade now
Ainsley Earhart is particularly
excited about this she's from South
Carolina and that may be a factor here
but they seem to just be gushing and I
think part of it is Ainsley Earhart
herself is from South Carolina and so is
Tim Scott and then on the other hand I
think they're desperate for someone
other than trump it really doesn't seem
like DeSantis has what it takes so maybe
they're interested in Tim Scott and they
say don't underestimate him by starting
at home yeah he's a really nice guy I
love South Carolina and what's ironic
he's he's positive he's mild-mannered
he's seeking to form a coalition of
traditional conservatives and
Evangelical Christianity and moderate
sounds great Ainsley please send it down
Republicans yeah they're just screaming
hello what's going on sarahwood he is
now a rock star in that area no
bitterness this is how far Charleston
has come he's got 22 million dollars
he's got a Super PAC that's got 13
million dollars anyone who dismisses Tim
Scott is uh you will regret that well
right I don't know why you'll regret it
but you will he's got 22 million it
sounds it sounds like
98.2 percent of Republican voters are
currently dismissing Tim Scott I was in
his uh treasury that according to the
SEC is the most any presidential
candidate has ever had at this point wow
you know I almost I almost feel bad
because I feel like almost Tim Scott's
too good for politics there you go he's
too good of a candidate he's too good of
a guy uh is this weird or is it just me
he's such a great guy I'm gonna be a
preacher and he did put out an ad that
is now running and Elon Musk came out
and said that is a great ad there you go
that clip from decoding Fox News which
who continues to do great work on
Twitter
um the Elon Musk seal of approval uh and
we know we know everything Elon Musk
touches turns to Gold of course Tesla
stock down about 80 percent and Twitter
in shambles so Tim Scott don't
underestimate him as 98.2 percent of
current Republican primary voters are
doing and uh we will see how Tim Scott
does in the meantime let's talk a little
bit about DeSantis Trump more than 100
Trump officials former Trump officials
are now backing Ron DeSantis for
president
but if you think it matters Maga does
not care disclaimer this is a Fox news
report it appears as though they are
properly sourcing this but it is a Fox
news report an interesting detail in its
own right the headline over 100 former
Trump Administration officials back to
santis for president quote a proven
winner the officials have formed a
coalition called the eight-year Alliance
viewing DeSantis as a viable two-term
candidate exclusive Fox News has learned
that more than 100 former Trump
Administration officials have formed a
growing Coalition backing Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis to be their
nominee according to multiple sources
within the group The eight-year Alliance
says the santis is a proven winner a
contender with a depth of policy proven
by what he's done at the state level and
a leader who does what he says all of
those seem to be lies I don't think
anything there is true the primary
motivation of the group sources say is
to promote a candidate they feel would
be a viable Contender for two
presidential terms something they see in
DeSantis they also want to prevent
former president Donald Trump quote
immediately becoming a lame duck
President should he win back the White
House considering the polarizing effect
his persona has had on American politics
uh now they're using the wrong word
they're using the wrong effect it says
the polarizing affect I believe that
that is incorrect but we'll get into
grammar more today in the uh in in the
voicemail segment so uh what's
fascinating about this is that Maga
voters do not care and we've talked more
about becoming a victim of the very
monster you created that's something
we've talked about before the monster
that is Maga does not care that you know
we don't know who's in this group but oh
John Bolton doesn't like Trump anymore
William Barr doesn't think Trump is the
right person to lead the Republican
party we don't care those were losers
that Trump had to fire and then when you
say to them well why did Trump hire them
in the first place I thought he was
great at hiring oh no forget about that
forget about that so you know again we
look at the polling Trump continuing to
climb last week he breached 55 support
he continues to climb he is now Beyond
56 support we mentioned last week that
DeSantis dropped below 20 for the first
time and I don't even know how long a
very very long time this may even be
when was the San DeSantis was last below
20 in October
and DeSantis is again below 20 and by
the end of the week he may be below 19.
the Maga voters do not care about what
Republican officials who once worked for
Trump have to say they are for Trump we
are going to actually this Friday in the
Friday feedback or the feedback segment
as it may be called
um We're going to see cultists who
straight up say
I will not vote for anyone else it's
Trump or nothing that is it so uh this
is not likely to be a group of former
Trump officials that has much if any
impact on the primary just look at the
polling it is a blowout for Trump he uh
it's his to lose is where I would leave
it hey quick reminder Monday Memorial
Day there will be no show we are taking
off the federal holiday
but there will be a one-day membership
special the likes of which you have
never seen before there are not many
such examples that I can tell you uh get
on my newsletter at davidpackman.com and
then Monday morning you'll get a
beautiful email telling you how to Avail
yourself of this historic membership
discount quick break much much more
today
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's talk a little bit about conspiracy
theories and fear-mongering and using
fear as a tool to influence we're going
to look at one of the usual suspects
Tulsi gabbard but we're also going to
look at a guy named I this I hesitate Dr
John Campbell not a medical doctor and
relevantly not a medical doctor in a
second segment this may surprise some of
you but we will get to that let's start
with and the theme Here is using fear
and and you know irritating and scaring
people agitating and scaring people
Tulsi gabbard was on Fox news's The Five
yesterday and Tool c i I know that the
word is now in the in the the Lexicon
sanctimoniously
bemoaned the use of fear to manipulate
people and of course Tulsi herself is
one of the people who has used fear to
manipulate people particularly since
coming out against the Democratic Party
party and becoming an anti-vaccine
anti-trans spokesperson of sorts so
let's start as it makes sense to do
listening to what gabbard herself said
and then we'll talk about why it's
particularly Rich that she make this
claim does anybody ever get
held for any wrongdoing it's it's
frightening that the answer to that is
probably no at this point they can
continue to lie one of the things that I
I took away from the statement that the
gorsuchets wrote was gorgeous here that
he used covet as the example but really
what we know throughout history going
back to the cold war in the Post 9 11
now this new cold war is that when we
have people in positions of power
fomenting fear it makes it easier for
them to take away our freedoms and so
the big warning signal kind of the red
alert for everyone is as soon as you
start to see people in power over hyping
a situation or a threat fomenting fear
we have to go back and remember Benjamin
Franklin's famous quote right that those
who would give up essential Liberty to
purchase a little temporary Safety and
Security deserve neither security nor
Liberty well said poignant words from
Tulsi gabbard now of course Tulsi has
done a campaign for a while now
portraying herself as the victim of the
fear-mongering by the Democratic
establishment where people said oh tool
sees a wolf in sheep's clothing
Tulsi is one of the great practitioners
of fear-mongering to influence and
manipulate herself and she uses the
fear-mongering as a tool to advance her
interests and her Ambitions she wants to
be seen and unfortunately some fell for
it and saw her as this principled
anti-war activist who will always expose
the lies of the fear mongers and the war
mongers but in in reality she has turned
out to be and I want to be accurate a
pro-authoritarian
conspiratorial fear-mongerer who
actually has fomented the very fear and
division among Americans that she
pretends to go after when she has called
Democratic leaders War mongers who will
get us into whether it's World War four
or five or nuclear Armageddon
that was fear-mongering that made no
sense and was not factually based in any
way check out her appearance on the Joe
Rogan program rather than ever
addressing the substantive criticisms of
her foreign policy views or explain why
did you meet with Syrian dictator Bashar
al-assad in 2017 she simply uses fear to
portray herself as this persecuted
almost whistleblower who was exposing
the corruption of the establishment and
if people ask too many questions about
why she met with that dictator then next
thing you know it'll be 1984. she has
said that whistleblowers and dissenters
were being silenced by the government
and that therefore we all need to worry
about eroding democracy and freedom with
no real substantive criticism of the way
that the Trump Administration
single-handedly made a free press the
enemy of the people which actually is
something that we should be afraid of
and of course it's always is without
specifics about who is it exactly that's
doing any of this stuff and there's so
many examples in October of 2022 she
posted a video on Instagram which
accused the Democratic party of stoking
anti-white racism and undermining law
enforcement when the reality is that
police have not been defunded and that
the so-called divisive agenda of
Democrats on race it's mostly a reaction
to the outrageous anti-woke stuff from
the right but that's not what she tells
you she just makes you afraid of the
Democrats and the things that they're
going to do and we could go on you know
when she spoke at CPAC
um she fear-mongered about how the Biden
vaccine mandates and so-called lockdowns
were attacks on civil liberties and
personal freedoms the likes of which we
will never recover from and it will be a
slippery slope into woke a stand or
whatever ignoring the public health
benefits ignoring scientific evidence
and all these things
he wants to sanctimoniously go after
those who use fear when it's hard to
imagine someone who has used fear more
than Tulsi herself so there's that let's
now go to another sort of example of
this uh Dr John Campbell all right so
listen some of you know who John
Campbell is some of you don't John
Campbell is a PhD in nursing who has a
YouTube channel that blew up during the
covet pandemic and he would provide a
mix of sensible information and analyzes
but he would also dabble in anti-vax and
some sort of stranger stuff that he
would flirt with and people would write
to me and they would say David Dr John
Campbell is a doctor who knows about all
this stuff why why aren't you in
lockstep with him and you know when ju
when we talk about Dr Jill Biden
she has a PhD in education there's no
possibility that anybody thinks Jill
Biden's a medical doctor right but not a
medical doctor PhD in education the
difficulty with Dr John Campbell is that
he is talking about medicine he's
talking about medications and vaccines
and treatments and pandemics he has a
PHD in nursing specializing in online
teaching
okay now this doesn't mean that
everything John Campbell says is wrong
but so many people see someone called Dr
John Campbell talking about medicine and
they assume you're talking about a
medical doctor it's not that a PhD in
nursing is worthless it's just that he's
not a medical doctor and during the
pandemic people would email me email me
email me saying listen to this doctor
and what he's saying okay
he now is feigning outrage that a new
mRNA flu vaccine
is doing phase one trials with only 50
people
except that's what phase one trials are
and he has even said that without
feigning outrage in the past so this is
another example
creating fear generating uncertainty
firing people up let's listen here he is
talking about the clinical trials of the
MRNA flu vaccine uh the number involved
up to 50 healthy volunteers 18 through
to
49 years of age
so this is direct from their website
this is not me this is not me having a
joke here
not a joke guys they really have only 50
people claiming
the National Institutes of Health in the
United States are claiming
that
by testing 50 volunteers healthy 18
through to 49.
they can assess the safety of this
vaccine okay
how how dare they now if you do any
research you find that phase one
clinical trials start with 20 to 80
people and you only need to look at his
own prior statements about phase one
clinical trials to realize that the
feigned outrage is fake here is Dr John
Campbell in February of 2020. this is
great video compiled by the bad stats
Twitter Channel they do a really good
job
where he says this is typical vaccine
and the
China vaccine are now being tested for
safety in animals
now the next stage after this in early
spring will be phase one human trials
now in phase one clinical trials the
drug or the vaccine in this case is
given to a relatively small amount of
healthy volunteers
totally normal in phase one clinical
trials it's given to a small number of
healthy volunteers August of 2022 same
thing now uh
that's the molecule there apparently
right phase one trial has been done on
healthy volunteers already so this is in
way on on its way next few months report
from 42 patients
and if that's a good quality truck now
no no problem there okay so listen this
is not about uh to be honest I haven't
seen any of John Campbell's content for
a long time now it's not about going
after him uh as a bad person or whatever
what I can tell you is the following
um there's no reason to now start
stoking skepticism about the MRNA flu
vaccine because the phase one trial has
50 people that's normal John Campbell
has on numerous occasions told us phase
one trials have a small number of people
here's one with 42 people no totally
non-reactive and now he feigns outrage
that this is it's not a joke folks
they're really assessing this based on
50 people that's how a phase one trial
works so you know again just understand
what your sources are Google simple
things it would take one second to say
how many people are normally in a phase
one clinical trial there is nothing to
be outraged about I very much look
forward to the data about this mRNA flu
vaccine maybe we will get ourselves a
flu vaccine that is more effective than
the ones that have sometimes floated
around over the last few years which
sometimes are only 20 to 40 effective
sometimes it's more but sometimes it's
only 20 to 40 percent I would love a
more effective flu vaccine that should
be the focus okay this is just so funny
it's sort of like it's not even really
adding insult to injury it's adding
injury to injury the day after Trump was
found liable for sexual assault and
defamation of e Gene Carroll uh in order
to pay her five million dollars he went
on his CNN Town Hall
and he made more disparaging comments
about Eugene Carroll and many of us said
sounds like potentially more defamation
CNBC reports Trump faces a 10 million
dollar defamation Claim by E Gene
Carroll after his CNN Town Hall remarks
he might end up owing more money because
of that nonsense that he said about her
e Gene Carroll filed court papers
seeking very substantial monetary
damages of no less than 10 million
dollars from Trump in light of recent
scathing remarks he made about her at a
CNN Town Hall Trump's comments occurred
a day after that jury awarded Carol 5
million in Damages for being sexually
abused into Fame by Trump she said Trump
raped her in the mid 90s in addressing
room of the Bergdorf Goodman Department
Store in Manhattan
it is continuing it is continuing the
lawsuit says Trump's defamatory
statements post verdict show the depth
of his malice toward Carroll since it is
hard to imagine defamatory conduct that
could possibly be more motivated by
hatred ill will or spite
uh they go on to say Trump falsely
stated that he did not sexually abuse
Carol that he has no idea who Carol was
and that Carol's now proven accusation
was fake and made up by a whack job
Trump also insulted Carol's character
downplayed his sexual abuse of her by
asking what kind of woman meets someone
and then within minutes plays
hanky-panky in a dressing room
um it's happening again
and you really without spending too much
time on this you really have to be a
very special kind of person you could
say delusional you could say narcissist
whatever to do a town hall the day after
you lose a defamation suit in court are
ordered to pay five million bucks and
then within 24 26 28 hours go on CNN and
make more of the exact kinds of
defamatory statements that you just lost
a case over so at this point will Eugene
Carroll be able to collect these
millions I don't actually know the
answer to that legal experts who have
weighed in say probably but it could
take a while
and now you may be adding even more onto
it is Trump doing this because he
genuinely thinks he's never going to pay
is it because he doesn't care about the
money which would be very much unlike
Trump or is he just confused about what
defamation even is let me know in the
comments I certainly have no idea
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with Thomas
Gabor who's a criminologist and author
of five books on gun violence including
American Carnage shattering the myths
that fuel gun violence uh Tom really
appreciate your time uh today thanks for
joining me my pleasure to be with you
David so I mean let's just start with a
very simple premise and see if there's
anything to it some of those in the
United States who don't want to see any
additional gun safety regulations or
laws put in place say they wouldn't do
anything to reduce shootings anyway is
that a claim that we can actually debunk
with with data do gun safety regulations
reduce shootings
uh certain ones do and uh you know I
just came across another report today
that showed for example that red States
at states that are uh run mostly by
government a governor who's a Republican
or a republican
legislature which tend to have weaker
gun laws have much higher gun mortality
rates so there's a lot of evidence that
first of all there's a correlation
between gun ownership and gun mortality
there's a tendency there's gun ownership
levels go up in the states and there's
huge variations there uh they there
tends to be an increase in gun mortality
or gun deaths and gun homicides as well
so and as well we see when we rate
states in terms of the weakness or
strength of the gun laws the stronger
the gun laws the lower gun mortality
tends to be what can you give a couple
of examples of the types of regulations
that are effective and then maybe a
couple of examples of the ones that
maybe aren't so much
okay well a good question first of all
I've studied gun licensing around the
world and that requires a much thorough
more thorough background check than we
do here in the United States where you
have interviews with law enforcement you
have reference checks and so forth and
those countries tend to do a whole lot
better than we do and we see some states
that have some kind of owner licensing
such as Connecticut that have done
better than other states and they've
seen gun homicides go down another one
is storage safe storage seems to make an
enormous difference or what we also call
child access prevention laws so when we
have consequences
for people not securely storing their
guns in terms of legal consequences that
seems to make a difference because for
example uh we've seen many School
shooters these young men uh who've
either often obtained the guns not
always but often from the home or the
home of a relative and these guns were
not secured now as far as what doesn't
work uh because you know it's only in
the last few years that the federal
government has been able to conduct
research because there's been an attempt
by allies of the gun lobby to stop all
research in this area we hear a lot
about Universal background checks and I
like to make a clarification there
because what that means is that and this
is what people are seeking that every
individual buys a gun
has to have a background check so today
we have this you might call it a
loophole where if you buy on the private
Market you buy through the internet or
from gun stores you don't need to go
undergo a background check if you not
bought from a licensed dealer so I'm all
for that however the background check
system also in my view is broken but if
all we do is expand background checks to
all sales it's not sufficient because
they're enormous problems with the
system itself it's a two minute check of
three FBI databases and so we've had
people like the Parkland shooter who
showed all kinds of disturbing signs but
because he didn't have a criminal felony
record he was able to buy his AR-15
legally from a gun store so we need the
analogy I use is you know we pretty well
have Universal checks when we get on the
plane everybody gets checked but the
second question is not just does
everybody get checked but how good is
that detection right it lets through a
lot of guns and explosives then you can
check everybody uh but it's not
sufficient so what I'm saying here is
the background the quality of the
background check system itself has to be
improved I don't believe to just
expanding background checks is
sufficient what about ideas uh like
restricting the ability to purchase
certain Firearms to individuals of a
certain age so maybe if you're under 25
certain Firearms would not be legally
purchasable I mean with all these things
you can always say well then that person
will figure out how to get that firearm
illegally but it's like maybe they won't
some of them won't
right and you know that argument that
you know criminals will always be
criminals and it's such a gross over
simplification yeah you know and
therefore we can't stop somebody who's
determined to get a gun well first of
all a lot of gun violence isn't
committed isn't premeditated it's
spontaneous so if you happen to be
carrying around the gun and you get into
a fight or a road rage incident you're
more likely to pull that gun but the
other thing is that if we use that logic
we get rid of all laws because you can't
stop
all a molestation the rain for homicide
and so forth so uh but some people are
deterred and you make it more difficult
because what's easier than allowing
somebody who's shown some Disturbing
Behavior to simply because they don't
have a criminal record on file
especially a felony record to just walk
in and to purchase a gun in two minutes
right uh you know and they could be also
very aggravated angry about something so
uh I think though the age issue that you
mentioned would be helpful because we do
have quite a few people are committing
gun violence
after that it becomes much more
difficult legally because a person can
argue in court that well I'm you know
I'm old enough to go fight for the
country I'm old enough to vote you know
so uh you know you don't have the right
to kind of abridge my rights and Tom we
lost we lost Europe we lost your audio
just for a second where I think what you
were saying was it's easier to restrict
based on a based on age before people
are 18 was that the argument you were
making but that these in between ages
can be tough legally
yeah though you know 18 to 21 I mean
that's passed in a number of states and
it passed in Florida as well before the
legislature tried to uh repeal that yeah
um so 18 to 21 I say is probably as high
as you can go got it uh and there are
people challenging that as well
saying that they can vote they could
serve the country at 18 and so forth so
they should be able to purchase a gun
but leaving the legal arguments alone I
think 18 to 21 certainly those are some
of the most active years for people who
commit gun violence so raising that age
can be helpful
I want to talk about the issue of mental
health and there are so many aspects to
this you know on the one hand
colloquially speaking without diagnosing
anyone
and when I think about a mass shooting
it seems that we would say anyone who
gets to a point where this is something
they would go and do
they're probably quote mentally ill in
some way because no quote sane person
would do that this is a very simplistic
thing to say but in some sense many of
us would say no sane person who's
emotionally regulated and whatever would
ever commits such an act so in a sense
certainly mental health is a component
but what do we really mean when we say
that are we talking about somebody who
has anxiety and sees a therapist what
what is it exactly that we're trying to
get at when we talk about mental health
how do you believe the mental health
layer should be applied to the gun
safety regulations layer
well we call it the mental illness Dodge
there's a world of difference between
saying that somebody has a severe mental
illness like schizophrenia uh bipolar
disease psychosis or something like that
and only four percent of people who
commit violent crimes in the country
have a severe mental illness now what
you're talking about is often
individuals who are agitated
in fact one of the frightening
statistics in this country is that over
20 million individuals have serious
anger issues they're people who can have
a short trigger if you wish and are
quick to anger have impulsive anger
issues and also own guns this is a much
bigger problem so yes I mean when you're
talking about somebody who commits a
mass shooting or even a a shooting of an
one individual that they're agitated
they're angry but we all get angry at
times and so there's a world of
difference between somebody suffering
from major mental illness and they're
usually more of a danger to themselves
in terms of suicides and they're more
likely to be victims of crime we see
that with the homeless some of the
homeless mentally ill who are victimized
to different cities but they're much
less of a concern unless they also had
in addition to a serious mental illness
A History of Violence I'd be more
concerned with people who are ready
at a moment's notice to deploy guns
against Intruders or people who may be
an intruder you know these recent
incidents where somebody took her turn
in the wrong driveway and was shot at
and somebody else who knocked on the
wrong door I'm more concerned about all
these people now because they've been
sold the gun lobbies narrative that
you're safer with a gun in the home and
you know the gun lobby has done a lot to
stoke people's fears and they're ready
they have 40 percent now of people have
guns in the home have the guns loaded
and accessible that's what I'm worried
about and if they also have a short
trigger and they're also afraid very
very afraid uh because this fear has
been stoked for decades now I'm more
concerned about those individuals
because the guns are at the ready and
they're primed to commit an act of
violence yeah you're getting to now
going Beyond mental illness into a
cultural component and one of the things
that is different in the United States
than in many other countries where I've
spent time is that there is a gun
culture which I describe it as it sees
Firearms as a more valid way to resolve
interpersonal issues frustrations
political issues ETC which access aside
and of course we have to talk about
access access aside I don't see in a lot
of the other countries where I've spent
time is this intangible cultural
difference a reality in the United
States
well you know this is what we take on
one of the myths we take on in our book
American Carnage because in reality uh
first of all there is no
all-encompassing gun culture in the
United States we have entire regions
like New England where you have gun
ownership levels in certain areas of
only 15 to 20 percent right only a third
of American adults are gun owners uh now
uh if you're talking about a minority of
individuals who you might say have a gun
fetish in stock a large arsenal of guns
we're talking about maybe what we call
the super owners who are six percent of
the American population and they own
two-thirds of all the guns wow that
doesn't make them all dangerous at all
but these are the people who have more
of a gun fetish if you want to call it
that and some of them are just
collectors but the vast majority of the
population isn't like that but let me
tell you what's changed is in 1977 the
National Rifle Association got taken
over by a very extremist group of people
and they have now spent over 40 years
trying to convince Americans that if you
arm yourself in the home and carry guns
you're going to be a lot more safe the
other thing they did is because with the
decline of hunting and the end of the
draft and the military draft was where
many people were introduced to guns and
the increasing urbanization of the
country there was a real crunch on the
gun industry so they started pushing
this Narrative of self-protection so
this is only about 40 years old this
narrative that we should all have guns
were safer with guns in the home
carrying guns in fact in the
1800s most of the states banned the
carrying of concealed firearms so we
actually in the United States have a
history going back to the revolutionary
period of regulating Firearms even
having citizens forming a militia and
asking them once a year to show up at
the Town Square to show why the guns you
have and those guns could be seized by
the militia if there was an attack on
the country or some Revolution to put
down so we've had a history actually the
old west you had gun ordinances but it's
more recently the last 40 years that
we've departed from that history and
that what you call a gun culture is
really an attempt by extremists and the
gun lobby to promote the idea of the
Armed citizenry being safer but we see
that it's nothing you know it's so far
from the truth and what we're seeing is
the opposite more mass shooting more gun
deaths children now the number one cause
of death of Americans up to 19 is is
gunfire and so forth so things have
really moved in in the opposite
direction from what they're claiming
the book is American Carnage shattering
the myths that fuel gun violence we've
been speaking with Thomas Gabor
criminologist really appreciate your
time and insights today thank you David
it's been a pleasure
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
so failed former president Donald Trump
is continuing to build up the story that
he's the victim everyone's treating him
so unfairly the E Gene Carroll verdict
was unfair the 2020 election results
were unfair the impeachments were unfair
the Mueller probe it was all completely
and totally unfair Fox News is treating
him very unfairly and I'm going to show
you a couple of examples of this from
the last 24 hours and remember that the
Trump family may be the most
thin-skinned public folks that we have
seen in a very very long time Donald
Trump appeared yesterday on I so I
always am confused by what these shows
are I believe the channel is real
America's voice which I still don't know
what that is is it a YouTube thing does
it stream I don't know the name of the
program is apparently just the news no
noise they interviewed Trump by phone
Trump plagued by more audio issues
echoing to high heaven and says that he
he has been violated as badly as anyone
there is no greater victim than Donald
Trump apparently I think I've been
violated as badly as anybody is that's
ever walked there's never been any
violation like this I've been violated
beyond belief he's been more violated
than the woman he was found liable for
violating in a Bergdorf Goodman
Department Store in the 90s certainly
he's a bigger victim than she is
according to him as a political it's
really a political persecution everybody
knows it and there's never been anything
like it and frankly if I didn't fire
James Comey uh I probably because that
was a coup that was a whole crew attempt
it was not a coup and we beat it but we
beat it with we beat some bad bad guys
unfortunately there haven't been
repercussions because people haven't
taken it up you need you know that's
exactly how I feel about much of the
Trump Administration they tried a coup
there were some really bad guys and
unfortunately there haven't been many
repercussions that that's exactly how I
would assess the Trump presidency but he
is continuing on this I'm a victim
parade and then continuing it over on
Truth social
where he said quote I don't know e Gene
Carroll I never met her or touched her
except on a celebrity line with her
African-American husband who she
disgustingly called the ape I wouldn't
want to know or touch her I never abused
her or raped her or took her to a
dressing room 25 years ago in a crowded
Department Store where the doors are
locked she has no idea when or did
anything else to her except deny her
capital F fake made up story that she
wrote in a book it never happened is a
total scam unfair trial
Trump engaging caps lock for the last
part of that and then just continuing
truth Central page two the Carol Case is
part of the Democrats Playbook to
tarnish my name in person much like the
now fully debunked Russia Russia Russia
hoax the 51 intelligence Agents FBI
Twitter files and so much more it is
being funded and tried by Democrat
operatives although this was denied by
them and when they got caught in the LIE
the Clinton appointed judge would not
let us use it in trial time will prove
him to be highly partisan and very
unfair where's the dress she said she
had and then Trump continuing
shifting his ire towards Laura Ingraham
of Fox News where he said quote Laura
Ingraham on Fox News just did a hit
piece on me there go her ratings showing
some polls which indicate that Rhonda
sanctimonious may do better against
Biden than I would when actually polls
show that I do much better against Biden
than Rob the poll you're looking at now
wrong your which has me doing far better
against crooked Joe was just put out by
Fox I am sure unhappily I'm also leading
to Sanctus by over 40 points in primary
voting watch Greg Kelly on Newsmax at 10
pm just endless endless meanwhile Barack
Obama met with a bunch of future
entrepreneurs and folks working for
non-profits discuss the importance of
service and also explored the coming AI
Trend you know it like you couldn't have
a bigger contrast between what these
former presidents are up to and Trump is
not stopping but he is still winning the
message continues to be
a b c d e f g that makes no sense that
Trump did and yet Maga continues to
support him and they will almost
certainly make him the Republican
nominee unless something changes you
know when we talk about Republicans
claiming to have principles and then
completely ignoring those principles it
often is when it comes to things like
economics oh the debt and deficit we
really only care about that when the
president's a Democrat all right I
gotcha or uh you know business
regulation we don't want to regulate
business until it becomes inconvenient
then we want to regulate business but
even with these so-called culture War
social issues these are the absolute
biggest Hypocrites it turns out that
anti-drag everything she's against drag
shows drag queens drag Kings everything
Marjorie Taylor green
has a boyfriend he's the guy from right
side broadcasting network I know and uh
it turns out he is dressed in Drag
and of course she's defending him so
here's the video that has now been
Unearthed here is Brian Glenn in drag
saying he kind of likes wearing his
pantyhose take a look at this
I can tell you I don't think I think a
lot of people up now they're all hashtag
I am up of course come and check it out
here so I saw on Saturday I'm kicking
these shoes off but I may keep the
pantyhose on it just feel kind of good
actually I'm not gonna pee in them I
promise he might might keep his panty
hose on so that's Brian Glenn in drag so
of course Marjorie Taylor green would
denounce this right because she's
against this she says this is grooming
and this is dangerous and it's obscene
and no she defends it Marjorie Taylor
green taking to Tweeter where she posted
quote I'm literally loling Brian Glenn
dressed in drag for Morning News in
Dallas years ago reporting on an
upcoming local theater production and
the morons over at Patriot takes think
this is an attack Brian loves the
throwback and is reposting laughing
crying Emoji the left is so stupid oh oh
okay okay we know that they are
hypocrites on the big issues that
deficit business regulation Etc but it
seems like they are truly Hypocrites
about everything even the social issues
even the culture War issues all of it
does it matter why you dress in drag now
before it was oh no no when men dress in
drag it's predatory and it's bad and
it's grooming and it's dangerous and all
of these different things now it's well
no hold on if you're dressing in drag to
promote a theater production then it's
okay if you dress and drag to I guess
read stories to kids that's what's bad
it's not the drag it's the fact that
they're doing it around children or
whatever the case may be these people
are completely and totally vapid there
is nothing there
and they are hypocrites on every single
one of these issues Marjorie Taylor
green at the absolute top of the list I
know people keep writing to me saying
David you should really cover this
relationship with Brian Glenn because
Marjory Taylor green claims to be a
Christian and sanctity of marriage and
all these different things it seems
almost like it's certain that she was
with this Brian Glenn Guy having an
affair even when she was still married
before she was separated and getting
guys I don't care yeah like obviously
I'm sure she's a hypocrite Lauren
bobert's now getting divorced even
though she said Christian people aren't
supposed to get divorced and they stay
together you work through all these
different things they're Hypocrites
they're all Hypocrites I really don't
care about her personal life other than
the hypocrisy but even like the affair
uh all these people who preach the Bible
are having Affairs many of them not all
of them I want to be careful it's not
new but she is the same type of pathetic
hypocrite that we've been following for
a long time so there it is uh
anti-dragmargery Taylor Green's
boyfriend in drag in this particular
particular case it's fine we have a
voicemail number and that number is 219
to David P
I don't remember when it was yesterday
the day before
I pointed out that when someone said
less it's actually fewer
and now I'm getting attacked as an
intellectual douche
listen to this hey David I was just
listening to your show today and you
like made fun of someone for saying
lesser instead of fewer or less instead
of fewer and I just thought that's kind
of below you you know there's a lot of
really intelligent people out there who
don't know that that's how you're
supposed to use the word myself included
I'm I'm a very smart educated high IQ
Personnel I believe you didn't know that
so I just think it's kind of a silly
thing to make someone make fun of
someone for and it just makes you seem
like you're being a little bit of an
intellectual douche so okay so listen
this is actually something that it
there's a backstory to this
I used to get very confused with less
and fewer and just a few years ago I was
getting crushed for it in the comments
and then now it's sort of like a joke
that I pointed out when other people do
it not being an intellectual douche not
being condescending very smart people
mix that up all the time I speak English
as a second language it had to be
explained to me in explicit detail let's
not take everything personally and it
really sounds like this guy's saying I
see myself as incredibly smart like my
IQ is really really high and I didn't
know that so therefore it must not be
important you must be making fun of
people let's all relax okay it's fine
it's fine if you were less than okay not
a big deal we have a great bonus show
for you today
a truck crashed near the White House
and a Nazi flag was reportedly found uh
uh outside of the truck which was in the
truck and it is again raising questions
about what is going on here secondly
Ireland is going to start requiring
cancer warnings and calorie counts on
alcoholic alcoholic beverages this is
something many in the U.S have been
advocating for saying listen we put a
lot of this stuff on cigarettes we
should put it on alcohol as well we do
have surgeon general's warnings on
alcohol about pregnant women but some
people want to see more and Ireland is
doing more we will discuss and lastly
Ron DeSantis has created a police
program to lure officers to work as
police in Florida who have violent
records in their pasts why is this being
done does it make any sense is it a good
idea we will deal with all of those
questions and more when producer Pat
joins me on today's bonus show get
instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at joinpakman.com it's cheap
quick and the most direct and important
way to support our program and remember
that if you would like you can get on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com and
Monday morning you'll get an email
telling you how to sign up for
membership at a dramatically discounted
rate that's Monday Memorial Day just get
on my newsletter at davidpackman.com
foreign